yes indeed he's here Jeremy Paxman of
Sinn Catharines College Cambridge
question master of university challenge
and for 25 years in quiz the general on
the BBC's Newsnight programme he's also
the author of a book the sum of
describers with you in Frank his memoir
of four decades in front of the camera
called a life in questions welcome to
you are these son who make this
accusation right they're the reviewers
are very good other reviewers said that
you avoided the questions all the
serious questions about you well you do
do your worst then as all I say to you
okay well I want to ask you first of all
not about yourself but about America you
were out there for panorama we did a
documentary what did you make of Donald
Trump's victory um like everyone else I
was at that thing were you there at the
American Embassy on Tuesday night I was
I was I was in America well afraid I was
and I made the mistake of wandering
around at one o'clock in the morning
saying believe me Hillary's gonna win
and I was made to look extremely foolish
so um I was as surprised as anybody else
but you'd have to accept that Hillary
was the most awful candidate wasn't she
she was absolutely useless she may have
been qualified she did quite well in the
debates yes he may have been qualified
but that wasn't the point she failed to
give any sense didn't you think if
you're a political candidate you must
give a sense of what the country will be
like if you're elected and she failed to
do that
she fail to give any sense of purpose
and future and bright sunlit uplands and
all the other cliches she never did that
and I think that's why she why she lost
Trump did manage to do something
obstruct me that worries again I mean I
do think there quite a lot of
similarities with the mood for Trump in
the mood for Briggs it and it struck me
that well he's at once for free trade
and once but not well no not in the
detail but in terms of the public
response that was victims because the
more positive version if you like you're
throwing it all out I will to ratify the
winnings
losing side were critical of the status
quo which they should have been making
positive case for well ladies a point
yes you would agree with that well I
forgot what the point was now it was a
very long question now okay and one of
your conclusions writing your memoirs
and looking back on your career in
journalism is that you think it's all
been a bit of a waste of time is that
right well I don't think the whole thing
was a waste of time no that is that is
not right at all have you read the book
yeah yeah you're very critical of the
news business
I am critical of the news business and I
don't say it's been a waste of time I
fully accept that it's important my
argument is that people are endlessly
assailed with the news and you have to
ask yourself does it make any difference
I'm sorry I know this cuts to the core
of 24-hour news stations but does it
make any difference whether we know
something now or in an hour's time or
two hours time or three hours time
particularly since in the vast majority
of cases we can do nothing about it
news of a traffic jealous hours like
they're not satisfied without us
does yes well whose they are the
producers you know the people where are
they get them in here let's ask them
well but it does make a difference does
it because you inform people about
what's going on and they can know what
or they can take my argument is do we
need to know it so insistently so
urgently in a lot of new studios now
they make people like you or me stand up
to deliver the news why what's the point
why you sit for too long you get piles
that's one reason speak for yourself I'm
sorry to hear that Adam no but isn't oh
I mean what's wrong with standing up
today because it gives a full sense of
urgency and most of this stuff is not
urgent it's urgent that you know about
whether your trainers being cancelled or
whether to avoid a traffic jam or
something but actually you don't need to
know most of this stuff in the frenetic
way which is imparted to you so I don't
say it's a waste of time I think it's
important and I really strongly
passionately believe in holding powerful
vested interest to account yes but I do
think the general maelstrom of news is
something that we need to cast a cold
eye upon you as an interview you didn't
originate the phrase but you've long
been associated with why's this lying
bastard lying with me as what you have
in your mind is that what you had in
your mind when you're interviewing
politicians or others no I mean some
clown once asked me what the principal
ought to be and I happen to have been
reading the little arse of Bowie hair
only over the deputy editor of The Times
as he became he was he was asked on his
very first job he'd be making the tea
and he was given a job finally as a
reporter to go out and ask someone a
question and some nardole hack in the
reporters room said to him just ask
yourself why is this lying bastard lying
to me and I think it's a pretty sound
principle yes yeah I mean his add remark
quoted in your book here a life in
questions he says Paxman looks
disdainful and contemptuous and furious
with his guests because by and large he
is is that true
I don't know and remark and say what he
likes poor chap nobody's saying that
about you I also describe me as
genuinely angry and torture ya and
disdainful and contemptuous of your
guess well I'm not disdainful and
contemptuous of my guess any more than
you are you're not no okay just your
interview I think I'm interested in what
they have to say but I disdainful of
having bollocks talk to me yes of course
but I'm not so now I'm not disdainful of
Wallen
but the exit the exercise is really very
simple I think you must find this to you
the best questions are the very simple
questions there are those questions
about the simple interrogatives where
when why how those are the best question
I quite agree and they may teach you
something but successful interview I
think is one in which you learn
something and if you don't learn
something because you're being just
generally waffled that then I think you
are entitled to feel fed up yeah but you
know and remark and said what he likes
he's not the fount of all wisdom any
more than Piers Morgan well it may be a
la Piers Morgan maybe like $2
if I suppose sir yes yes he claims he's
a friend of his Jeremy Paxman we were
happily there thank you very much today
so thank you for having me was that it
that was very quick wasn't it it was
because you're so first they pay you for
this
they do indeed